-It is nice after the hurricane
to see you here dry.
-Yes, I know.
-Not in your iconic
black T-shirt.
[ Light laughter ]
-I saw your bit.
I know you enjoyed
our hurricane coverage.
-I enjoy
your hurricane coverage.
I enjoy the Anderson Cooper
black T-shirt.
How did you first
find your way --
-I was gonna bring out, like,
a little, tiny,
baby black T-shirt to give you,
but I couldn´t find one.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-There were all being washed
by me.
-How do you find your way
to a black T-shirt
in the first place?
-So, there´s a reason why
you wear a black T-shirt, like,
in the field or in a storm,
is because, "A,"
you´re wet all of the time.
-Yeah.
-And if you´re
in a light-colored T-shirt
and you´re dirty,
people are gonna comment
on how dirty you are.
-Yeah.
-If you´re sweating
and you´re not wet --
you´re just sweating -- then
they´ll comment on how sweaty --
and black or dark shirts
hide the sweat.
So there´s a reason for it.
-Yeah.
But I feel like you´re still
the only guy doing it.
-No. Are you -- no.
[ Laughter ]
Well, maybe so.
-Well, I feel like other guys,
like, wear slickers and coats.
And you will stay in
the black T-shirt longer.
-No, that´s not true. I´ll --
I´ll wear a -- I´ll wear a coat.
[ Both laugh ]
-Okay.
-But when you´re sopping wet,
it doesn´t matter,
like, you´re wet.
-Yeah.
-So no matter what you --
you´re wearing a coat,
but, like, the water comes in.
It´s like having people
throw buckets of water at you
for 13 hours.
-Yeah.
-You´re sopping wet.
You might as well, you know...
-Just rock a black T-shirt.
[ Light laughter ]
Do we -- We kind of made this
point on our show last week.
-Right.
-That we think you guys
should all go inside.
-[ Laughing ] Right.
-Can you make the argument for
why you have to be out there?
-I mean, look -- first of all,
we all do things which,
you know, you -- You´ve what? --
You´ve hosted the
CFDA Fashion Awards twice now?
-Yeah.
-Is that really necessary?
-It´s --
-Probably not.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And yet, there you are.
-There I am.
-By the way,
I hosted it once, so...
-Yeah. So you really know
the second one´s the dumb one.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But, look,
I just think it´s a --
it´s an incredible force
of nature.
And, you know, we want
to document what is happening,
and to see that up close is --
is a really extraordinary thing.
-The only thing --
the only argument I´ll make,
is I feel like part of it is you
guys tell people to stay inside.
-Right, and yet, we are outside.
-Well, also, if I´m inside,
and I know black T-shirt
Anderson Cooper is outside...
-[ Chuckles ]
You´re gonna go outside.
-I´m gonna go out
and try to meet you.
-When it really gets bad, people
do not go outside, thankfully.
-Yeah, that´s good.
-But the funny thing is --
I was -- I was, you know,
I was there for days.
And I´m literally --
You´re literally on air for,
you know, 10 hours at a time.
And it´s wind, and it´s rain --
I mean,
that´s what it boils down to.
And so by hour nine,
you´re like,
"Remember six hours ago
when I said it was windy
and rainy?
Well now it´s really,
really windy."
[ Laughter ]
"And it´s rainy, too."
But the only thing is,
my mom kept e-mailing me
while I was on the air
because --
-So your mom --
Gloria Vanderbilt.
-Yes.
-A very famous designer
and actress and model.
-Yes, yes.
She is now 93, and I just
got her to join Instagram.
-Uh-huh.
-And she has now become obsessed
with Instagram
and with her Instagram account
to the -- first of all,
my mom didn´t understand
what Instagram was.
And it took many times
for me to try to explain it.
She still didn´t quite get it.
But -- But then,
I made her an account,
because I thought
she might get a kick out of it,
and I promoted it
on my Instagram account.
And she went from zero to like
130,000 followers very quickly.
And I happened to be with her
as the count started going up.
It was like
Christmas times 1,000 for her.
She was like, "This is
the most incredible thing."
She had -- The idea that
anybody would be interested in
what she was doing thrilled her.
She had no idea.
-Instant addiction, then.
-Instant addiction.
-Yeah.
-To the point now she e-mail --
my mom never e-mailed me before.
She never called me
for most of my life.
[ Laughter ]
She now e-mails me
about 20 times a day,
and 10 of them are,
"Should I post this picture?"
[ Laughter ]
And what´s annoying is,
when she e-mails,
she doesn´t believe,
when she hits "Send"
that the e-mail
necessarily goes out.
So she´ll send three copies
of the same e-mail.
[ Laughter ]
So I --
And then -- then, an hour later,
it´s, "Maybe it should be
this picture."
And then I´ll finally say,
"Why don´t you do this picture?"
I´ve limited her.
I´d say,
"Look, no more than two a day.
You don´t want to be
one of those, you know,
people who needs
an Instagram intervention."
And then she´ll e-mail me, "What
should I say about the picture?"
I´m like, "You know what?
I got a job to do."
[ Laughter ]
I -- This -- I´ve --
-Does she have
any appreciation or sense
that you are
in the middle of a hurricane?
-No, no.
-Yeah.
-She´ll be like --
no, she really, really doesn´t.
Like, in fact, I e-mailed her
one time -- I e-mailed her back.
I was like, "You know, actually,
I´m -- I´m on the air.
I´m in Fort Myers.
You know, the storm is coming.
And I´ve been on
for nine hours."
No recognition of it.
-[ Laughs ]
-She´d just send another one
like, "Oh, sorry.
Well, let me just quickly ask
you, what about this picture?"
[ Laughter ]
So...
-Well,
you opened Pandora´s box there
by teaching
your mom to Instagram.
-I did, I did. Yes, yeah.
-That´s all on you.